hi there Steve Kaufman here I did a
video on accents and different accents
when we're learning and so I want to
follow that up with a video about
pronunciation how do we get a good
accent as it's sometimes called the main
thing in pronunciation is to be
understood and to speak clearly so we
don't have to sound like a native but
the native is the model that we want to
imitate we want to try to get close to
the way natives pronounce because after
all that's the that's the model I don't
want to pronounce English like a Spanish
person or a French person I want to
pronounce it like an English person it's
that that's the language that's the
standard we learn how they use words and
we learn to be as close as possible to
how they pronounce but we aren't going
to sound like them now how do we achieve
it in my view you have to do a lot of
listening and you have to be very
attentive and I find when I start a new
language
at first I can't pronounce the new
sounds I have a vague sense of what they
are but after a lot of listening it
becomes easier so I can always pronounce
much better three months in or six
months in and I can at the beginning so
like right now I've had a bit of
exposure been dabbling a bit in Polish
and I discovered that they have nasal
sounds there so that money for example
is pronounced pinyons it then you only
say when I first heard that for its up
written paid yawns it at least to me but
in fact in Polish it's written pinyon Z
so I have to get used to how that word
is pronounced I have to listen to it
over and over and over again it's very
important to listen and to listen to
things that we like and then we find
interesting that have resonance and to
pay attention so if we look for example
in the case of sweetie I was going to
say it's very important to listen to
authentic native speakers I think it's
very bad it's very unfortunate that most
language learners are in a classroom
think to other language learners and
non-native speakers and very often
people of the same language group so
French speakers are surrounded by people
speaking with a French accent
Japanese speakers are on surrounded by
people's deep with the Japanese accent
when they're learning English so they
shouldn't listen to those people they
should listen to native speakers and
hopefully not just some boring stuff but
some something of interest and that's
what we see in Sweden where people learn
English primarily because of their
exposure to television movies and pop
culture in English to something that
they like and they find interesting and
therefore Swedes pronounce English very
well
the present generation whereas I would
imagine a previous generation two
generations ago that didn't have that
exposure would have more of a sweet
ushak simply this big English and
because this week is now growing up
aren't getting their English from their
classmates they're getting English from
movies and television this opens up so
it's very important to do a lot of
listening to authentic content one other
thing when we first start into a
language there's a lot of things we
don't hear so I often hear people say
well should I learn you know Spanish
from Spain or Spanish from Mexico so the
long as well it doesn't matter you can't
hear the difference if you're learning
you know if you know our learning polish
is probably four or five different
regional accents I won't be able to pick
them up it really doesn't matter to me
at some point though as I've got used to
the language and it's kind of fuzzy of a
broad sense of how it's pronounced I may
find certain people whose voice and
whose pronunciation and whose diction
then the subject matter interests me so
then I will really concentrate on
listening to those people and trying to
imitate them now in order to imitate you
have to notice and you can't make
assumptions about how things are
pronounced based on on your own language
so in Japanese I often mention the case
and Canadians go to Japan I was in
business there and I introduced
mr.kato and they say hello mr. Hinkle
because k80 always had potato my father
used to say the Bank of Nova Scotia
instead of Nova Scotia you know he would
say born forward and squiggle for
squirrel where is it word is grow so
he's trying to interpose or you know
impose the values of those letters from
check in his native language on to
English instead of listening and being
attentive to how those things are
pronounced in English I'm not a great
believer in the international phonetic
alphabet I think to me it's more a
matter of finding a voice an accent a
person an authentic native speaker that
you like subject matter is interesting
like Kim Jung ha the Korean podcast that
I've been listening to I love listening
to his voice I love his intonation I'm
gonna listen to him and I'm going to
model myself in Korean on kim yu-na
model yourself focus on listening and
don't worry about how you sound because
you are going to get better if you allow
yourself to be exposed to to the
language and the other thing is you have
to want to be one of them I think
there's a large sort of psychological
emotional aspect to pronouncing if you
hang back because you're you're
reluctant to do you don't want to be a
fool so you sort of hang back in your
own pronunciation or in my own case I'm
comfortable speaking Spanish when I go
to speak Portuguese
I find myself hanging on to my Spanish
rather than just totally throwing myself
into pronouncing the way the Portuguese
do whether it be in Portugal or Brazil
so you really have to take that plunge
just let yourself go and do a lot of
listening so I think if we do those
things and we don't need to worry we
don't have to do all our listening you
know I just so much listening reading
when I learn a language not all of the
listing that I do is to people whom I
want to be like some of I miss some of
that I listen to for the content for the
language
to require vocabulary but then there are
some of it where the voice is so nice
the pronunciation intonation is so nice
that's where I really focus on that's
what I imitate insofar as my
pronunciations concern so I hope that's
helpful again I also caution that we
aren't going to sound like a native
speaker that in most cases we can aspire
to what we shouldn't be disappointed if
we don't reach that level and I'm far
more impressed by people who speak with
an accent but speak well and have you
know good use of vocabulary than I am
with people who seem to have very you
know native or almost native like
pronunciation but who can't really you
know express themselves eloquently or
precisely in the language so there you
have it just to follow up on that
previous video about accents is just
that I throw in a one on how to achieve
an a native light or close to native
light accent or what we might call
pleasing pronunciation in our language
thank you for listening